it's such a sop even down to like what
he's wearing right he always has to be
ready for battle he never takes off this
uniform even though when he's traveling
he's nowhere near any Battlefield like I
don't think he's ever anywhere near the
battlefield I think this guy is a TV
character he is yeah I mean he literally
was he played the president on TV but I
think he I I don't think this guy's ever
seen anything close to conflict they
they probably have been a secure
location because he's basically uh you
guys you guys have seen Hunger Games
right yeah in the second one they get
Katniss out you know of the games
they're like keep her in the basement
and have her make videos they don't want
her going to war because if she dies
she's the propaganda tool she's a
rallying cry that's what they're trying
to do with this guy I gotta be honest
he's the least inspiring guy they could
have gotten I mean seriously couldn't
they have gotten some like Dolph lungren
like type Ukrainian dude who's like
filming prop propo videos on the front
line Ukrainian